let's just worry buddy watching this
myself and Tom Halden agreed would spoil
the entirety of them okay here we go so
give us everything that happens
everything happens again so what happens
is is you'll sit down in the theater and
then a couple of logos will play and
then following the logos it's a story
about Peter Parker and his friends and
then that will end and then in this town
next year there will be another one but
that's what happens hashtag spoiler okay
well I preached in the interview guys
okay so so here's my question
starting with uh what are we gonna get a
spider-man Deadpool movie cuz I feel
like that's the one thing everybody
wants to know that's a big question and
I don't think I'm equipped to answer I
know that Kevin Feige is in the building
somewhere if you get the chance to sit
down with him
he's probably the most equipped person
on the planet to do tasks like I know
somebody grab him real quick yeah hey
get in the shuttle if you could appear
in any of the movies belonging to you
know characters we haven't seen in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe yet uh whether
it's my cameo were actually like
co-starring and teaming up in the movie
would you pick any character this hasn't
debuted in a like a team like x-men
fitness for I would like to do
spider-man and Wolverine there's a
really really interesting story in the
ultimate spider-man spider-man and
Wolverine swap bodies for a day and like
Peter Parker wakes up in Wolverines body
and that would be so funny and then
Wolverine wakes up in Peter Parker's
body and he like goes to school in
southern Peter Parker's like being this
really gross rude man and like starts
hitting on the school teacher and stuff
and then Wolverine who's this really
scary guys like oh hey guys you doing
[Laughter]
hey I'll be really really cool like sure
like like a like a 5 to 10 minute like
yeah like a little short
yeah really good idea yeah somebody
needs to make that I'm making it Java
okay oh yeah my question is if you had
spider-man's powers for a day mm-hmm
what pranks would you pull on Tom
another adorable runaway track of the
chairs yeah would be swing around New
York no see but you don't know how to do
it if it's only for a day but if you
thought spidey sense or Peter tingle
there's me be able to do it I love Peter
De Pere mmm Peter tingle it's very funny
it's funny okay
so I love the character of image right
like a wholly new interesting unique
character strictly for the movies but
you can't spoil anything so what do you
think the future of her character is um
I don't know I mean I think that the
coolest part is uh that she's like
stayed this kind of like John has kept
her is this like this this different
character you know I think what was
really important is that like she it
wasn't like that thing where Peter all
of a sudden likes her because she's
different and she's changed you come
back and you know she's like this
different person I think they kind of
are both the quirky weird kids that are
often like you know the outsiders and I
think that's why they find each other
and like see each other in that way and
like each other for all the weird quirky
[ __ ] that they have which is like really
sweet yeah and my character often is
like very like you know everything she
says although sometimes very like out
there and and blunt
it's always very like deliberate but
then like Peters kind of the only person
that makes her like stumble over her
words and trip up and so we
kind of just get to see I think a softer
side of her and get to see that she
really is just like a teenager at the
end of the day and I don't know Peters
kind of like breaks down her wall a
little bit yeah well we kind of building
on that right so like five years going
yeah the snow what's life like for you
guys cuz I mean obviously it can be
weird yeah I think when we meet our
characters in this film they don't know
yet they haven't really been given
enough time to process I mean this film
is a direct continuation from Avengers
endgame so our characters are still kind
of in this headspace of like we don't
really know what happened and this
European vacation is kind of an excuse
for our heroes to get out of New York
and to just enjoy themselves a little
bit and kind of forget about the tragedy
of endgame well that's kind of
interesting thing because you know we're
talking about a landscape absent Toy
Story mm-hmm like and and I'd have to
assume given the way Avengers endgame
ended like the Avengers as we know them
weren't really II don't know for a team
or anything but but overall we're like
the the whole tone of this movie and
like the future of what comes next I
mean I mean it seems like spider-man's
flying by the seat of his pants right
like what we see the I don't know that
this movie kind of has like seized all
the tragic stuff that that we've all
just like had to go through in the past
couple movies through like a more
comedic lens so we get a little bit of
happiness in our life after what we've
all been through so as viewers so I
think that's what Spider Man offers zap
offers like this warmth that like yeah I
think we'll have like you know you can
have a little fun and still like smile
even though like all these tragic things
have gone and then it punches you a few
times
my last question here like like having
with all that we just talked about you
know like the tone of the movie and and
how everything's gonna happen do you
guys think the aftermath of Avengers
endgame coupled with the whole you know
sequence of events in this film do you
think it brings a three year three of
your characters closer together
absolutely yeah I'm not just a three of
us like everyone in the way everyone in
the world becomes a little bit close
like if you look at May is now hosting a
charity event for people that blipped
and stuff so it's kind of I guess maybe
brought people closer together yeah
absolutely awesome well I appreciate you
all